peine et on ira à l'éleveur aujourd'hui
évidemment nos équipes sont toujours sur
place mais puisque en thaïlande ça bouge
journée de vote
oui ça a été difficile mais c'est
peut-être un peu moins de que ce qu'on
en fait on appréhendait donc les bureaux
de vote sont fermés la base c'était jour
d'élections législatives des élections
anticipées qui visitent à mettre fin à
trois mois de crise politique on entend
tout de suite avec notre envoyé spécial
yvan côté alors yvan on rapporte quand
même des échauffourées mais somme toute
le scrutin s'est déroulé dans un calme
relatif
je te fais on craignait vraiment le pire
avec la fusillade d'hier qui a fait six
blessés mais finalement les bureaux de
cheveux teints qui ont ouvert ce matin
et la majorité 90% c'est assez
impressionnant le d'entre eux qui ont
permis aux thaïlandais de voter mais
malgré tout il faut se rappeler qu'ici
les manifestants prennent beaucoup de
place donc encore aujourd'hui ils ont
réussi à perturber l'élection à
plusieurs endroits dans le pays mais
surtout à bangkok où il ya eu des
confrontations l'intimidation aussi sa
force et la fermeture de 400 bureaux de
vote dans la capitale seulement en tout
à travers le pays
10 des 48 millions d'électeurs qui n'ont
pas pu se prévaloir de leur droit de
vote donc on peut parler d'une journée
passablement calme parce qu'elle pas eu
de blessés y'a pas une mort mais
beaucoup de frustration bon c'est
qu'avec ce scrutin yvan la première
ministre chinois hu qui est très
contesté voulait faire retomber la
tension est ce qu'on voit poindre la fin
de cette crise
en fait le problème en ce moment on
pense que cette élection pourrait créer
encore plus le soin guéret avait 7 il
faut comprendre que les manifestants ne
reconnaissent toujours pas les résultats
du vote
ils disent que le scrutin est truqué que
le gouvernement est corrompu dont déjà
on a annoncé en fin d'après-midi que
demain on reprenait la vue de nouvelles
manifestations
entre temps on a un gouvernement qui est
élu maintenant mais en raison des
perturbations du boycott aussi du vote
par les manifestants ils reposent
suffisamment de députés d'élus donc on
parle maintenant de paralysie politique
comment cette crise va se régler c'est
une grande question mais une chose est
certaine il ya plusieurs observateurs en
ce moment qui n'écarte pas encore une
fois la possibilité d'un
coup d'état donc vraiment ici rien n'est
réglé merci beaucoup il va en voir au
revoir